bon à tous merci de nous retrouver sur
public sénat favoriser l' embauche de
jeunes en cdi tout en maintenant
l'emploi des seniors dans les
entreprises
voilà pour l'objectif des contrats de
génération qui sont débattues cet
après-midi dans l'hémicycle du sénat
ce projet phare de françois hollande a
déjà été adoptée en première lecture par
l'assemblée nationale hier devant les
sénateurs michel sapin ministre du
travail a estimé qu'avec ce texte le
gouvernement entendait poursuivre sa
bataille pour l'emploi tout de suite
donc direction l'hémicycle poursuivre
l'examen de ce texte bonne après midi à
tous monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues la séance s'est ouverte le
compte-rendu analytique de la précédente
séance a été distribué il n'ya pas
d'observation je n'en vois pas le procès
verbal est adoptée sous les réserves
d'usagé
mais monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues chez notre profond regret de
vous faire part du décès de notre
collègue monsieur rené vestri survenu ce
matin il avait été élu sénateur des
alpes-maritimes le 21 septembre 2008 son
éloge funèbre sera prononcée
ultérieurement au nom du sénat je
souhaite exprimer nos sincères
condoléances à sa famille à ses proches
et au groupe ump
mes chers collègues par courrier en date
du 6 février madame eliane assassi
présidente du groupe communiste
républicain citoyen a demandé que les
projets de loi autorisant l'approbation
de l'accord france royaume des pays bas
pour ce qui est des rumbas relatif à
l'échangé de renseignements en matière
fiscale et l'approbation de l'avenant à
la convention france sultanat doman en
vue d'éviter les doubles impositions
inscrits à notre séance de demain jeudi
7 février sur examiné en séance publique
selon la procédure normale et ce nom et
non selon la procédure simplifiée acte
est donc donnée de cette demande dans la
discussion générale commune le temps
attribué aux orateurs des groupes
politiques sera de une heure le délai me
limite pour les inscriptions de parole
est fixé demain à 11 heures
est ce qu'il y à des oppositions je n'en
vois pas il est donc ainsi décidé par
ailleurs par lettre en date du 6 février
le gouvernement a demandé l'inscription
à l'ordre du jour du mardi 12 février
l'après-midi de la suite du projet de
loi portant diverses dispositions en
matière d'infrastructures et de services
de transports et de la proposition de
loi relative à la prorogation du
mécanisme de l'éco-participation
répercute à l'identique y afficher pour
les équipements électriques et
électroniques ménagers dans l'examen
était prévue le jeudi 14 février le soir
sous les ordres de leur dépôt des
conclusions de la commission mixte
paritaire sur le projet de loi portant
création du contrat de génération
éventuellement de la suite de l'ordre du
jour l'après-midi acte est donnée de
cette communication
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
l'ordre du jour appelle la suite de la
discussion du projet de loi adopté par
l'assemblée nationale après engagement
de la procédure accélérée portant
création du contrat de génération
je vous rappelle que la discussion
générale a été close
nous passons donc à la discussion du
texte en commission
et donc de l'article 1er je suis saisi
de plusieurs prises de parole dont celle
de madame génisson au titre du groupe
socialiste
elle n'est pas là donc madame michelle
meunier ou monsieur domaine c'est
monsieur le maine qui remplace madame
génisson monsieur lemay nous est la
parole
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre madame la
présidente de commission le rapporteur
mesdames messieurs chers collègues nous
voilà réunis aujourd'hui pour examiner
le contrat de génération qui je vous le
rappelle était le l'engagement numéro 33
du programme du président de la
république
il s'agit de répondre à une des
préoccupations majeures des françaises
et des français l'emploi le gouvernement
confronté à une situation sans précédent
en matière économique et sociale a
engagé dès son arrivée la bataille de
l'emploi avec pour objectif d'inverser
la courbe du chômage
cette bataille s'appuie tout d'abord sur
une méthode la valorisation du dialogue
social et la mobilisation concertée et
complémentaire de tous les acteurs et
actrices concernés et ça marche
cette bataille articule logique
offensive et défensive à travers une
véritable politique de l'emploi
je vous rappelle la création d emplois
d'avenir voté à l'automne dernier la
garantie jeunes annoncées à l'occasion
de la grande conférence sur la lutte
contre la pauvreté le renforcement et
l'allongement des contrats aidés et
enfin le contrat de génération qui nous
réunit cet après midi il s'agit
d'intervenir de manière forte et
volontariste en faveur des personnes les
plus exposées les jeunes et les seniors
car ces deux catégories sont aujourd'hui
condamnés au chômage dans notre pays
les chiffres sont frappants vous les
connaissez je le rappelle tout de même
24 % des personnes de moins de 26 ans
sont sans emploi et en parallèle le taux
d'activité des personnes de plus de 65
ans stagne à 45% ces chiffres sont
mauvais et nous place parmi les mauvais
élèves au sein de l'union européenne
l'originalité du contrat de génération
réside dans le fait qu'il relie ces deux
réalités
le difficile accès au marché du travail
pour les jeunes et le maintien dans
l'emploi des seniors
le contrat de génération se propose de
composer une solution durable pour les
uns des autres en privilégiant la
transmission des connaissances et des
compétences
c'est bien ce que propose l'article
premier de ce projet de loi évidemment
ce dispositif ne réglera pas tout à lui
seul tous les problèmes concernant
l'emploi il nous faut multiplier les
possibilités d'accès à l'emploi tout en
soutenant l'activité économique dans un
environnement national et international
difficile à plus d'un titre
mais le pire serait de nous résigner de
céder à la fatalité non nous devons
poursuivre notre soutien en proposant de
nouveaux outils pragmatiques efficace et
solidaire avec celles et ceux qui
souffrent et qui doutent de l'avenir
cet outil repose sur un pacte entre les
générations et doit maintenir dans
l'emploi 5 millions salariés partant en
retraite d'ici à 2020 et faciliter
l'entrée dans la vie active 2 6 millions
de jeunes ce n'est pas rien chers
collègues ce n'est pas rien il vise
aussi à changer notre regard sur les
âges à agir au coeur même des
entreprises notamment en encourageant la
transmission des compétences et à
refaire du cdi
la norme dans le monde du travail outre
la question de la transmission des
savoirs le contrat de génération donne
toute son importance à la formation et
j'insiste permettant ainsi aux jeunes
salariés de bénéficier d'un véritable
parcours qualifiants temps l'entreprise
mais dans notre pays la réalité des
petites entreprises et des grandes
entreprises est bien différente aussi ce
dispositif introduit des modalités
spécifiques en fonction de la taille des
entreprises ce qui permettra une
meilleure adaptation aux réalités et aux
besoins des employeurs et des salariés
et si le contrat de génération est le
fruit du dialogue entre partenaires
sociaux
il laisse lui même une très large place
à la négociation au sein même de
l'entreprise ce qui est très bien dans
les structures et plus de 300 salariés
la négociation sur l'emploi des jeunes
et des seniors ainsi que sur la
transmission des compétences est
fortement encouragée nul doute que ce
changement de culture et de méthode sera
productive j'en suis certain
pour terminer j'aimerais formé le voeu
que ce contrat de génération aura à
coeur à son niveau et à son échelle de
respecter les engagements du
gouvernement en termes d'égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes au niveau de
l'emploi car sein même des entreprises
notre pays nous faudra agir pour réduire
les écarts en matière d'accès à l'emploi
ac c'est toujours plus compliqué
toujours plus difficile pour les femmes
qu'elles soient jeunes ou moins jeunes
dialogue social protection des salariés
création d'emploi formation transmission
des savoirs des compétences égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes
voilà un cocktail pragmatique et
efficace pour renouer avec l'espoir en
matière d'emploi je ne doute pas que les
entreprises françaises petites et
grandes seront utilisés à bon escient
ces nouveaux dispositifs dans le cadre
de leurs responsabilités économiques et
sociales monsieur le ministre je tiens à
vous assurer du soutien des sénateurs et
sénatrices socialistes pour mener et
remporté à vos côtés
la bataille pour l'emploi merci monsieur
le maine la parole est à madame michelle
meunier alors la parole est à monsieur
georges labazée
merci monsieur le président c'est le
ministre mes chers collègues j'ai eu
l'occasion d'évoquer mon propos en
commission donc je vais leur et le
réitérer pour monsieur le ministre pour
rappeler qu'il serait important dans un
souci de coordination et de mise 10 ont
en commun dos des moyens des
collectivités territoriales et de l'état
que dans la mise en oeuvre du dispositif
concernant ces contrats de génération et
jeudi lorsque le texte qui n'en doute
pas sera approuvé que dans sa mise en
oeuvre soit menée les meilleure
coordination possible avec les
départements ou les régions où les
régions et les départements qui ont mis
en oeuvre dès beaucoup de dispositifs
souvent efficace mais qui mérite d'être
soutenu concernant en particulier les
tpe
concernant les petites entreprises
lorsqu'il s'agit de la mise en oeuvre de
la succession du remplacement des ont dû
du chef d'entreprise
et tout cela a fortement imprégné nos
débats donc je me souhaite que ce
dispositif que soit disons mise en
exergue soit 10 ont aussi identifié
région par région ou département par
département
toutes les institutions qui ont fait un
effort majeur
justement pour assurer les successions
dans les entreprises que nous puissions
bien coordonnée que l'action de l'état
sont maintenant bien coordonnée avec les
collectivités territoriales dans un
souci d'efficacité
merci mon cher collègue la parole est à
monsieur yves daudigny
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre madame le rapporteur mes chers
collègues nous sommes nous tous qui
sommes le calme en responsabilité en
région dans le département nous comptons
nous commune savons combien il est
difficile de favoriser le maintien et
d'aider à la création d'emplois des
trois départements picards laine et le
plus fragilisé
et avec un taux de chômage qui atteint
14,4 tout le monde malheureusement c'est
pas 14.5 le dernier soit 4 points
au-dessus de la moyenne nationale mais
près de 6 points supérieure dans la zone
de saint quentin et de 7 points en
thiérache
or ce projet associée aux mesures déjà
prises constituent un con c'est
simplement un espoir et il réalise
d'ores et déjà un grand progrès sans
même préjugé de sa portée
souhaitée de tous vous dans l'opposition
je le pense comme nous dans la majorité
sans effet déjà un grand progrès que
d'avoir su réinstaller le dialogue
social et resterait la dynamique de la
négociation d'avoir proposé est engagée
sur plusieurs fronts en même temps un
ensemble de mesures cohérentes d'avoir
enfin substituer à une approche
d'opposition entre les âges
celle d'une valorisation de leur
complémentarité
c'est aussi déjà un grand progrès que le
choix de ce gouvernement d'agir en même
temps sur tous les leviers possibles en
faveur de l'emploi le contrat de
génération n'est en effet que pas une
mesure isolée mais un dépens de
l'ensemble de la politique pour l'emploi
des crimes décliner dès après
l'alternance avec la grande conférence
sociale des 9 et 10 juillet 2012
l'accord national interprofessionnel
unanime d'octobre suivant qui font ce
projet puis les contrats d'avenir mis en
oeuvre par la loi du 26 octobre
entre temps le renforcement des équipes
de pôle emploi l'adoption du crédit
impôt compétitivité à venir la
traduction du récent accord national
interprofessionnel pour la sécurisation
du marché du travail
c'est encore un autre grand progrès que
celui du pragmatisme qui permet une mise
en oeuvre différencié pour s'adapter aux
réalités de chaque entreprise
le choix d'être ciblés et conditionnés
en faveur des tpe et pme ne peut qu'être
favorable notamment à la transmission
d'entreprises artisanales et agricoles
qui sont un enjeu majeur pour nos
territoires ruraux nous devons également
approuvé outre la mise en
complémentarité des compétences plutôt
que leur mise en concurrence la prise en
compte des
salariés handicapés quel que soit leur
âge s'agissant des modalités de mise en
oeuvre
je rappellerai simplement le résultat
qualitatif très formel la négociation
institué au sein des entreprises sur
l'emploi des seniors par la loi de
financement de sécurité sociale pour
2009 faute que soit prévu un contrôle de
conformité a priori au moment d'aborder
l'examen de la disposition phare de ce
projet de loi je voudrais alors je sais
pas si j'utilise le conditionnel ou du
futur ce que j'écoutais les
interventions hier je voudrais saluer
nos collègues sénatrices et sénateurs de
l'opposition à l'assemblée nationale
vous avez députés ont en effet choisi de
déposer et défendre avouons le
laborieusement de motion de rejet
préalable et de renvoi en commission
puis un amendement de suppression de cet
article 1er tel n'a pas été votre choix
mes chers collègues et cela devait être
souligné d'ailleurs malgré ses demandes
préalables de rejet et de suppression le
vote de l'opposition à l'assemblée a été
très partagés critique laborieuse en
effet et je dis car les raisons
présentées en faveur du rejet n'ont pas
convaincu et ne sont pas convaincantes
l'impact de ce projet serait d'ores et
déjà obéré par les choix de politique
économique et ne constituerait qu'une
réponse partielle aux attentes de la
jeunesse serait assez peu inter
générationnelle la procédure accélérée
mal traiterait le parlement bref aucune
critique finalement sur le fond du texte
et sur le dispositif lui-même
sinon à la marge dispositif que jean
pierre door à l'assemblée qualifie
spontanément de je cite belle idée en
défendant sa motion de renvoi en
commission
ce projet est connu depuis octobre
dernier
personne ne peut prétendre être
aujourd'hui pris de court
est il utile que je poursuivre dans
l'énumération de certaines
contradictions
personne ne conteste en tout cas on tous
les cas la gravité de la situation non
plus que l'urgence à agir
l'idée de contrat de génération l'idée
du contrat de génération fait-elle même
unanimité
cela a été reconnu surtout léman nombre
d'entre nous
ont aussi témoigné de la très fortes
attentes que suscite ce projet dans nos
circonscriptions aussi mes chers
collègues j'ai presque envie de vous
dire très simplement et en conclusion
allons-y ensemble dans cette bataille
pour l'emploi
je vous remercie merci la parole est à
monsieur roland courteau
merci monsieur le président s'il ya un
domaine où le mot urgence prend tout son
sens
urgence sociale urgence économique c'est
bien celui de la lutte contre le chômage
c'est bien celui de l'emploi toutes nos
forces doivent être tendu vers ces
objectifs
comment en effet ne pas réagir quand on
constate que l'entrée dans le monde du
travail pour les jeunes commencent par
l'expérience de la précarité par le
temps partiel subi par les petits
boulots suivies de périodes de chômage
et mais aussi par les basses très basses
rémunérations comment ne pas réagir
quant à l'autre
à l'autre extrémité de la pyramide des
âges
le taux de chômage des seniors est
dramatiquement haut et au delà de la
souffrance
on pourrait parler de véritable gâchis
des compétences et des talents
bref il n'est pas possible il n'est plus
possible d'accepter que la période de la
vie active durant laquelle l'emploi est
stable et convenablement rémunéré soit
de plus en plus courtes et se situe
entre 27 et 55 ans il était donc
important et urgent de se préoccuper des
deux extrémités de la pyramide des âges
en favorisant l'accès à l'emploi pour
les jeunes et le maintien dans l'emploi
pour les seniors les contrats de
génération sont une réponse à cette
double préoccupation même même s'il
convient de préciser que la politique de
lutte contre le chômage ne saurait se
résumer au seul contrat de génération
mieux mieux ce qui caractérise aussi les
contrats de génération
c'est l'alliance des âges en fait le
caractère innovant du dispositif c'est
bien le binôme des salariés oui mes
chers collègues je considère que les
contrats de génération comme vient de le
dire
yves daudigny constitue bien l'un des
leviers permettant d'atteindre les
objectifs fixés par le président de la
république c'est-à-dire inverser la
courbe du chômage fin 2013 et je pense
très sincèrement au delà de leur
caractère innovant que leur force
principal c'est d'être issu du dialogue
social le dialogue social devant être
comme cela a été dit à la fois un
principe mais aussi une méthode
excellente méthode
d'ailleurs monsieur le ministre que
celle qui a été choisie pour réformer
notre modèle de relations sociales
mais il ya encore mieux car l'on
pourrait aussi parler de révolution
sociale culturelle économique
en effet les contrats de génération ont
aussi pour finalité de créer un climat
pardon un ciment quand générationnel au
sein de l'entreprise
et pourquoi pas au-delà avec la
transmission des savoirs et des
compétences
enfin et c'est aussi un objectif
ambitieux ce dispositif
ce binôme de salariés devraient
encourager les entreprises à oeuvrer en
faveur d'une véritable dynamique de
gestion active des âges et non pas de
gestion par les âges
l'autre point positif du contrat de
génération c'est l'aide dont pourra
bénéficier un chef d'entreprise seniors
qui envisageraient d'embaucher un jeune
en cdi avec pour objectif de lui
transmettre ensuite son entreprise est
là bien sûr ce sont les entreprises
artisanales qui sont concernés j'en
termine monsieur le président oserais-je
dire que ces contrats de génération
peuvent être d'excellents à
sénateur du recrutement pour chacune des
extrémités de la pyramide des âges les
jeunes et les seniors
on serait je dire qu'enfin est remis au
goût du jour la solidarité
intergénérationnelle
les jeunes seront considérés comme des
acteurs à part entière et les seniors
seront confortées dans leur aspiration à
rester actifs
décidément c'est là un très bon projet
de loi dans la bataille pour l'emploi
qui est engagée un projet qui recueille
monsieur le ministre
notre total soutien merci monsieur d
non on va laisser les différents
orateurs et joue donnant la parole après
monsieur le ministre monsieur des
essaims oui parce que hier soir monsieur
le ministre
lorsque en fin de soirée
vous avez dit que vous vouliez dire
quelques mots pour nous permettre de
passer une nuit tranquille
malheureusement j'ai réfléchi est ce que
vous m'avez dit monsieur ministre et je
n'ai pas beaucoup dormi j'ai réfléchi
j'ai réfléchi je suis comme ça moi le
ministre dit quelque chose le soir
ensuite j'y réfléchis j'y pense
monsieur le ministre nous avait dit oui
oui vous comprenez des contrats
génération cent mille par an vous nous
avez dit c'est pas qu'on va créer cent
mille emplois
mais ça va permettre aux entreprises
hésitante de faire le pas
c'est pas ça qui m'a troublé monsieur
ministre mais j'ai voulu compléter parce
que j'ai réfléchi j'ai dit l'effet
d'aubaine
on parle on dit oui mais les entreprises
à embaucher quand même mais elles ont
rembauché comment les entreprises
peut-être en cdd alors qu'on a montré
qu'il est important pour les jeunes
d'avoir un contrat à durée déterminée
pour avoir un logement pour avoir une
vie d'adulte une vie d'adulte épanouie
si ça permet de transformer grâce à cet
effet d'aubaine
le contrat à durée déterminée en contrat
à durée indéterminée c'est encore mieux
monsieur le ministre
voilà quoi jeu
ce soir et après les débats en hémicycle
j'ai réfléchi et j'ai même continuer et
j'ai dit c'est quand même intéressant ce
qui se passe parce que ça oblige
l'entreprise à réfléchir à savoir
comment elles s'organisent
madame debré vous avez dit vous mettez
des contraintes aux entreprises
mais enfin l'entreprise vous qui dites
comme nous d'ailleurs ce n'est pas
d'abord l'argent ce n'est pas d'abord
l'économie vaisselle social c'est
l'homme d'abord où la femme est bien on
tient compte de la réorganisation de
l'entreprise
on tient compte de la transmission du
savoir et on tient compte du rôle de
l'entreprise la société
et voilà à quoi servent les contrats
génération non simplement à convaincre
les hésitants monsieur le ministre mais
à assurer aux jeunes bien assez dit
lorsque c'est possible à faire le pas et
ça permet à l'entreprise à réfléchir à
son rôle social dans la société mais je
m'arrêterai pas ici ce qu ensuite
monsieur le ministre j'ai vu que j'ai
réfléchi j'ai réfléchi j'ai peu dormi
mais surprise dans le citoyen j'ai
réfléchi j'ai réfléchi et monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre avait dit
je suis dans l'action et et bravo mais
j'ai réfléchi comment faire en sorte que
cette action ne soit pas de l'agitation
parce qu on a connu ça sous le septennat
précédent fin le catena précédent où on
se déplacer aux élections il faut rester
dans l'action et pas dans l'agitation et
pour éviter que ce soit de l'agitation
comme je lé dit lors de mon intervention
générale hier
il faut éviter que simplement on
embauche les jeunes cette fois ci les
seniors cette fois là et ensuite que ce
soit d'autres personnes qui sont
expulsés parce qu'un projet de gauche ne
peut accepter que personne ne sort
chômage qui les vingt ans qu'il est 57
ans qui les 60 ans ou qui les 35 ans on
sait les dégâts que très le chômage
encore une personne s'est suicidé parce
qu'il avait des problèmes d'argent
il ya quelques quelques jours
on ne peut accepter que ce soit à jeunes
un ancien ou une personne des zones de
la maturité
on ne peut accepter personnes donc
monsieur le ministre que ce projet est
une cohérence que nous réfléchissions
ensemble à une réorganisation de
l'économie que nous réfléchissons
ensemble à d'autres relations sociales
que nous réfléchissions à une société de
coopération et je fais dire que ces
contrats de génération soit l' amorce
d'une réflexion écosocialiste que nous
pourrons avoir ensemble comme vision de
société et comme projet pour nos
citoyens
je remercie
merci monsieur des essarts madame
procast ya monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre j'avoue que moi
j'ai dormi sans problème et sans penser
au contrat de génération
même si la prise de parole sur cet
article concerne effectivement l'article
est pas comme mes collègues le contrat
de génération vous nous aviez bien
signalé madame le rapporteur monsieur le
ministre que les contrats de génération
était d'abord et avant tout destiné à
ces jeunes puisque maintenant nos jeunes
doivent attendre des années et des
années avant d'avoir un cdi et nous le
regrettons tous il accumule des cdd
successifs des périodes de chômage d
intérim avant d'obtenir effectivement ce
fameux cdi mais nous n'avons pas parlé
et peut évoquer de la situation des
stagiaires
or les stagiaires surtout ses rangs
monsieur le ministre est depuis de
nombreuses années nous nous en
préoccupons et nous avons fait avancer
la législation pour les stagiaires
je ne comprends pas pourquoi dans les
catégories de des contrats de génération
les stagiaires ont été exclus nous
savons bien que les jeunes font des
stages un stage de stages souvent des
stages de six mois des stages qui
peuvent être de un an avant
éventuellement d'avoir un cdd et avant
de passer en cdi
pourquoi ne pas avoir voulu inclure les
stagiaires dans
dans le contrat de génération
naturellement vous en doutez j'ai essayé
de déposer un amendement co signé par un
certain nombre de mes collègues mais le
couperet de l'article 40 est tombé
or il me semble sur cet article 40 je
m'interroge parce que le gouvernement a
prévu un budget et une enveloppe
maximale
donc si les stagiaires étaient intégrés
c'est pas pour autant que l' enveloppe
serait dépassé et alors même si tu
allais quelqu'un est en tout cas par
rapport au vote qui sera le mien sur
sept articles 1er et sur le contrat
j'aimerais savoir quels sont vos
intentions
est-ce que vous avez l'intention de
pouvoir faire une place aux stagiaires
qui travaillent déjà enfin qu'ils sont
déjà stagiaires dans cette entreprise ou
non est ce que vous voulez faire évoluer
si vous voulez pas intégrer des
stagiaires j'aimerais bien que vous
puissiez me dire pour quelles raisons
ils ont été exclus je ne participe pas
aux amis et c'est vrai que je n'ai pas
regardé de très près ma deuxième
remarque sur le le schéma général des
contrats de génération je voulais fait
en commission c'est que je regrette un
petit peu cet âge de 57 ans parce que 57
ans s'est montrée du doigt des personnes
en disant aux entreprises bah 57 ans ils
sont vieux d'abord je pars du principe
que maintenant l'âge de la retraite à 62
ans
donc 57 plus trois ans a fait 60 ans ça
veut dire qu'à 62 ans on les vide donc
vous suggérer qu'ils sont les personnes
âgées donc la logique si c'est pour les
amener jusqu'à l'âge de la retraite
serait que ce ne sont pas 57 ans mais 59
ans l'âge mais surtout plutôt que de
maintenir dans l'emploi
j'aurais aimé que l'on dise plus
précisément dans la rédaction même si
c'est induit que c'est aussi l' embauche
des plus de 57 ans si vous tenez à cet
âge ou de 55 ans que c'est aussi
l'embauchent or la rédaction et nous y
reviendrons tout à l'heure et à c'est en
lisant alambiquées et je pense que c'est
pas un signe assez fort pour l'embauché
des personnes de 55 57 59 ans et plus
merci monsieur le noir sur le président
chez mini mes chers collègues je veux
d'abord réagir à ce qu'a dit jean
desessard je m'adresse à lui mais je
pense qu'il est parti se reposer
mes chers collègues je ne peux pas
accepter nous pouvons pas accepter
d'entrer dans dans cette démonstration
qui désirent pas celle du ministre qui
consiste à dire nous à gauche on ne peut
pas accepter qu'il y ait du chômage
laissant entendre que ce n'est pas un
problème qui interpelle également les
élus de droite c'est un problème
national ce un problème qu'ils engagent
tous car nous sommes des responsables
politiques dont je ne veux pas que
monsieur de sessa reçoit le seul à
vouloir dire dans cet hémicycle et qu'il
est porteur d'une volonté qui ne
seraient pas partagés par ceux qui
siègent ici dans l'opposition et à
droite singulièrement deuxièmement ce
qu'a dit catherine procaccia est tout à
fait juste nous avons nous avons un vrai
problème de stage en france
combien de fois nous rencontrons des
jeunes qui ont besoin d'ailleurs un
stage pour accompagner leur formation
initiale pour simplement avoir un
contrat d'alternance et qui n'arrivent
pas qu'ils n'arrivent pas à ouvrir les
portes des entreprises les entreprises
semblent rétive semble frileuses à
l'idée de former des jeunes dans le
cadre d'un contrat d'apprentissage ou
simplement d'un stage
or souvent ces jeunes se retrouvent
réduits quand on parle de stage à une
présence sur la pointe des pieds d'env
une entreprise pendant quelques jours
voir pendant quelques semaines ils
n'apprennent rien c'est dire une charge
pour l'entreprise ont sur le ministre
nous souhaiterions disposer de signe
fort laissant entendre que ce problème
est pris en compte dans le cadre du
projet de loi que nous que nous sommes
en train de discuter je vous remercie
merci mon cher collègue monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président
merci de me donner la parole juste
quelques éléments de réponses d'abord
pour remercier tous ceux qui de nouveaux
sont intervenus pour souligner les
caractéristiques de ce contrat de
génération et donner leur appui à la
démarche est le plus souvent au texte
même si comme tout texte celui-ci est
également perfectible
je voudrais donner juste que quelques
éléments de réponse monsieur labazée
week-end là bas sur le président comme
en commission vous avez posé la question
qui est très importante de la
compatibilité de la connexité et au fond
de la capacité des politiques nationales
et locales de se renforcer l'une l'autre
pour atteindre le meilleur résultat
possible
c'est vrai sur les emplois d'avenir
évidemment puisque nous avons absolument
besoin pour réussir les emplois d'avenir
d'une très bonne coordination avec les
régions de manière à ce que les
programmes de formation ya pas que l qui
sont concernés en terme de force et
probables de formation soit adapté c'est
vrai s'agissant toujours des régions
pour ce qu'on a appelé parfois d'une
manière générique des emplois tremplins
disons l'appui à la création d'emplois
associatif de manière à ce que ce soit
bien coordonnée avec le dispositif
emplois d'avenir mais c'est également
vrai et c'était le sens de votre
question dans le cadre du contrat de
génération tout particulièrement pour
les politiques de transmission
d'accompagnement de transmission de ces
entreprises
j'ai été président d'une région où la
question de la transmission de ces
petites entreprises se posent comme dans
toutes les autres jours de france est
effectivement nous avions mis comme
d'autres régions en place des
dispositifs d'accompagnement donc je
pense qu'il appartiendra aux
collectivités territoriales de prendre
en compte le contrat de génération tel
qu'il est pour ensuite adapter leur
politique ça me permet de redire ici
très fermement et très clairement que la
l'emploi politique de l'emploi
c'est une responsabilité de l'état ça
doit rester une responsabilité de l'état
mais que par définition la situation de
l'emploi sur son territoire concerne les
collectivités locales au niveau de leur
propre territoire
les communes évidemment les départements
évidemment les régions évidemment et
donc la nécessaire coordination de ces
politiques est gage d'une bonne
efficacité c'est ce que je souhaite voir
mise en oeuvre sur l'ensemble du
territoire
france sinon sur les autres questions
qui ont été posées
bien sûr il ya des questions dont nous
aurons à débattre
amendement après amendement mais madame
nous avons eu ce débat sur est-ce que
fixer une borne d'âge s'est montrée du
doigt
non c'est simplement fixer les
possibilités d'application d'un texte de
loi
c'est vrai aujourd'hui comme c'était
vrai hier car objectivement les bords de
d'âge comme l'on dit que ce soit 25 ans
soit 50 ans soit 55 enfin 57 ans soit 60
ans que ce soit 62 ans âge de départ à
la retraite paraît-il on fixe bien des
bornes d'âge pour pouvoir appliquer les
textes et les dispositions ça n'est pas
montrée du doigt
ça n'est pas traitée de je ne sais pas
quoi trop pagé telle ou telle catégorie
c'est simplement permettre une mise à
dispo de mise en en musique normale et
habituelle de l'ensemble de notre
dispositif voilà cinquante sept ans
c'est le principe du maire générale 6 à
60 ans au bout de trois ans le jeune
ayant fini de bénéficier de l'aide
le plat personne veut rester jusqu'à 62
ans départ de à la retraite tant mieux
un autre jeune d'ailleurs pour affaires
couple avec lui-même et permettra
toujours à cette personne plus âgée à
cet aîné de faire bénéficier
l'entreprise d'un contrat de génération
il ne perd pas sa valeur entre
guillemets sous prétexte qu'il aurait
pris simplement trois ans de plus au
contraire il peut être bonifié y compris
dans l'accompagnement du jeune et dans
la capacité à accompagner le jeune dans
l'entreprise
mais une dernière question à laquelle je
voudrais répondre n'est pas sain parce
qu'elle ne date pas d'aujourd'hui c'est
celle des stagiaires un stagiaire c'est
normalement pas un salarié de
l'entreprise
d'ailleurs au fond le détournement du
stage c'est quand on enfin un salarié
comme les autres dans l'entreprise donc
il est bien légitime que nous n'ayons
pas considérer le stagiaire comme s'ils
étaient en cdd ou comme s'ils étaient en
intérim dans l'entreprise
c'est normalement une autre question se
sont d'ailleurs d'autres dispositions
qui sont là pour protéger
les stagiaires contre des abus
d'utilisation des stagiaires
parce que quelqu'un qui est stagiaire
pendant très longtemps sur le même poste
et qui est remplacé sur le même poste
par un autre stagiaire
c'est un détournement de dispositions et
non pas à l'accompagnement du jeune nous
en serons tous d'accord j'en suis
persuadé et la question que vous me
posez c'est est-ce que dans ce texte non
ce n'est pas l'objet du texte mais ce
que dans d'autres textes ou à d'autres
occasions
nous souhaitons mettre en place des
dispositions qui à la fois encourager
les entreprises à accueillir en vrai
stage parce qu'on a des entreprises qui
sont réticentes par rapport au stade on
connaît bien beaucoup de jeunes qui
courent après les stages parce que c'est
obligatoire dans leur cursus et qui ne
trouve pas donc il faut inciter les
entreprises à accueillir des stagiaires
mais il faut dissuader pour ne pas dire
condamner les entreprises qui font de
l'abus de stagiaires
nous en connaissons beaucoup trop les
uns et les autres c'est un sujet qui n'a
pas échappé à notre sagacité
c'est un sujet qui a d'ailleurs était
abordé d'autres d'autres occasions y
compris par les partenaires sociaux
et donc je vous proposerai dans les mois
qui viennent nous n'avons pas tous fini
avec le contrat de génération n'auront
même pas tous fini avec la loi sur la
sécurisation de l'emploi qui verra dans
quelques semaines donc il nous aurons
d'autres occasions de pouvoir en
discuter en tout cas merci de votre
question elle pose tout de bonnes de
bonnes questions et j'espère avoir
apporté des réponses qui permettront à
monsieur des essarts je voulais terminer
par lui de passer de bonnes nuits
parce que je suis persuadé qu'en fait ça
nuit a été bien meilleure que celle
qu'il nous décrit car il a totalement
raison en nous décrivant un des
indicateurs de réussite
il est normal lorsqu'on élabore un texte
de loi qu'on essaye de voir si ce texte
a bien marché ou mal marché et quels
sont les deux indicateurs car il ya deux
indicateurs pour voir si ce texte de loi
aura réussi ce projet de loi aura aussi
il ya un premier c'est celui auquel je
vous répondais hier mais ils le savaient
qui est parce que la question était
posée combien de jeunes vont ils pouvoir
bénéficier de ce dispositif est donc
pouvoir trouver un emploi c'est à cette
question là que je répondais en parlant
des 100000 qui était notre objectif est
de là
capacité pour les entreprises à sauter
le pas à oser embauché qui est la
citation y compris financière pouvait
leur permettre de franchir mais la
deuxième indicateur c'est celui que
votre sommeil agité a permis de faire
apparaître en toute lumière c'est celui
de la diminution du nombre des contrats
à durée déterminée ou autres contrats
précaires dont les jeunes sont
aujourd'hui les premiers à pâtir dans le
système français
il faut donc que le nombre des cdi dont
les jeunes peuvent disposer augmente
aussi à l'occasion de ce texte il ya un
objectif quantitatif et il ya un
objectif qualitatif et c'est au vu de
ces deux objectifs que nous pourrons je
l'espère considéré ce texte comme
pertinents merci monsieur le ministre
nous arrivons à la discussion de
l'amendement numéro 11 du du groupe
udi us et c'est monsieur marseille qui
le défend oui monsieur le président
auparavant je voudrais faire un rappel
au règlement fondant sur l'article 45
aline et un de notre règlement au sujet
de deux amendements l'amendement 18 et
l'amendement 21 qui ont été déposés par
les membres de mon groupe et qui se sont
vus opposer l'article 40 auquel il a été
fait allusion par ma collègue procas ya
tout à l'heure c'est un article qui est
beaucoup utilisé et nous avons nous
avons beaucoup de difficultés à
comprendre
l'interprétation de l'article 40 en la
circonstance puisque s'agissant de
l'amendement 18 il s'agit de la
transformation d'emplois précaires en
emplois permanents et donc enveloppe
constante et pour l'amendement 21 il
s'agit de pouvoir lever le dispositif en
cas de difficultés économiques des
entreprises donc ces deux amendements au
demeurant ont été acceptés à l'assemblée
nationale et discuter et donc nous
aimerions comprendre pourquoi ici au
sénat ils ne peuvent pas l'être
je vous remercie merci monsieur
marseille donc acte vous est donné de
votre
déclarations et je vous propose donc de
défendre l'amendement numéro 11
s'agissant de cet amendement monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues il a pour objet d'intégrer aux
objectifs généraux du contrat génération
la garantie d'une formation qualifiante
pour les jeunes non diplômés qui serait
concerné par le dispositif s'agit à nos
yeux d'un enjeu capital
comme nous l'avons développée en
discussion générale selon nous les
emplois d'avenir aurait dû être
réservées aux jeunes les plus éloignés
de l'emploi tandis que les contrats de
génération devrait être réservée aux
jeunes peu qualifiés dans cette optique
il est donc fondamental que le contrat
de génération soit systématiquement
assortie d'un plan de formation pour les
jeunes peu diplômés qui en bénéficieront
sans la garantie que le contrat de
génération offre une expérience
qualifiantes et diplômantes le
dispositif aura du mal à générer de
l'emploi pérenne sur leur merci merci à
vis de la commission madame le
rapporteur
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues monsieur
marseille je voudrais faire deux
remarques par rapport à votre amendement
numéro c est faire une proposition votre
souhait de formation des jeunes non
diplômés
je pense que nous le partageons tous
c'est qu'il est complètement légitime
pour autant je voudrais vous dire quand
il ne me semble pas souhaitable de
modifier d'alourdir cet article en qui
définit le contrat de génération dans
ses grands objectifs à l'alinéa que vous
précisez l'alinéa 8 décrit de contrat de
génération dans ses grands objectifs
donc mettre là la question de la
formation me semble un petit peu gênant
la deuxième remarque que je voudrais
faire c'est comme en demandant que des
jeunes diplôm déjà non diplômés soient
recrutés en contrat de génération et
qu'il puisse accéder à des formations
diplômantes
je pense qu'il y à un risque d' obtenir
l'effet inverse de l'objectif visé par
ce que on peut avoir des entrepreneurs
des chefs d'entreprise qu'ils soient
inquiets d'avoir à engager dans le cadre
du pôle information puisque je rappelle
que les chalands compte recruter en cdi
sont des salariés de l'entreprise et
qu'ils ont accès au plan de formation de
l'entreprise qui normalement ne prépare
pas à des formations diplômantes
certains des formations qualifiantes
mais pas à des diplômes et je crains que
du coup on ne pénalise les jeunes non
diplômés qui vont peut-être se retrouver
par cet effet là exclus du recrutement
dans l'eau dans le contrat de génération
donc je vous proposerai soin de retirer
cet amendement
nous aurons l'occasion d'y revenir plus
tard avec l'amendement numéro 14
si tel n'était pas le cas la commission
a émis un avis défavorable à cet
amendement
merci madame à vis du gouvernement
monsieur le ministre président
rapporteur à donner les arguments qui me
paraissaient de moi monsieur le sénateur
je vous propose vraiment qu'on voit
cette question au niveau du de
l'amendement numéro 14
je pense que c'est plus sa place dans
son texte et nous aurons je pense à
progresser ensemble à ce moment merci
monsieur le ministre monsieur marseille
il est maintenu non je vais donner suite
à la proposition du gouvernement aux
tirs et nous en arrivant à l'amendement
numéro 2 toujours monsieur marseille
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
chers collègues l'objet de cet
amendement est de faire en sorte que le
dispositif de contrat de génération se
concentre sur l' embauche de jeunes
salariés le maintien dans l'emploi des
salariés seniors
en effet dans sa rédaction actuelle le
texte poursuit l'objectif je cite de
favoriser l'embauché le maintien en
emploi des salariés âgés cette
formulation brouille à nos yeux les
finalités du dispositif qui est censé
bien sûr faciliter l'embauché des jeunes
mais aussi faciliter le maintien dans
l'entreprise des salariés les plus âgés
on vient donc de matières clairement ce
double objectif dans l'énoncé des
objectifs généraux afin de ne pas
prendre le risque de disperser les
efforts
merci à vis de la commission madame
demontès monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues
l'amendement que vous proposez supprimé
la possibilité d'embaucher un senior
pour remplir les conditions fixées par
le contrat de génération il me semblait
que ce matin en commission vous nous
aviez dit que vous retiriez cet
amendement bon ça n'est pas fait donc on
en discute
je vais donner au nom de la commission
un avis défavorable mais surtout je veux
expliquer pourquoi
bien sûr l'objectif du contrat de
génération c'est d'embaucher un jeune
c'est de maintenir dans l'emploi senior
mais nous et puis c'est aussi de
transmettre les compétences
troisième objectif qu'il ne faut jamais
oublier mais il y à des entreprises qui
n'ont pas de personnes de plus de 55 ans
dans l'entreprise
parce que il y à des entreprises jeunes
avec des jeunes dans l'entreprise et il
me semblerait tout à fait dommageable
d'empêcher cette entreprise de recruter
un chômeur de 55 ans pour faire un
binôme avec un jeune dans le cadre d'un
contrat de génération donc si vous ne
retirez pas cet amendement la commission
a émis un avis défavorable
si mal à un avis du gouvernement
monsieur le ministre même opinion mais
juste alors qu'il ventait je suis pas
sûr que le sénateur vous ne recréent
tier votre votre amendement parce que la
réalité statistique des entreprises les
regarder attentivement j'ai regardé
combien il y avait une entreprise où il
y avait des jeunes cons mais élevé
d'entreprises où il y avait des plus de
57 ans et je me suis aperçu qu'il y
avait des entreprises qui pouvait
embaucher des jeunes où il n'y avait pas
de personnes âgées de plus de 57 ans et
donc dans ces cas la suite été dommage
de pouvoir se priver de la possibilité
de ce binôme
mais comme il y en a par dans
l'entreprise plus âgé il faut bien
l'embauché et donc c'était une ouverture
qui a d'ailleurs été souhaitée par les
partenaires sociaux eux-mêmes c'est un
enrichissement par rapport au texte
initial que nous avions proposé aux
partenaires sociaux de la part des
partenaires sociaux pour permettre à des
entreprises qui ont des besoins
d'embauchés de prendre un plus jeune est
un plus âgé
le plus âgé
il viendra pas de l'université enfin ou
alors ce sera à l'université pour tous
voilà je voulais éviter le terme de
diversité pour tous non il viendra d'une
autre entreprise où il a acquis une
expérience
donc il est parfaitement capable de
transmettre aussi son expérience oblige
à devoir je veux pas argumenter plus
parce que je pense que ce serait
vraiment privé les entreprises qui en
ont la possibilité de la capacité
d'embauché est un jeune et un plus âgé
et d'aci lutter contre le chômage des
plus jeunes et des plus âgés
merci monsieur le ministre il est retiré
monsieur marseille vit retirée merci
amendement numéro 58 de la commission
madame demontès oui monsieur le
président il s'agit de rectifier une
faute de français parce que nous ne
bougeons pas et nous ne maintenons pas
en emploi mais dans l'emploi merci à vis
du gouvernement monsieur le ministre
alors je le mets au voit quels sont ceux
qui sont pour son amendement
son adoption par d'un avis contraire je
n'en vois pas il est adopté nous en
arrivons l'amendement 42 rectifié
laisser madame debreu qui le défend
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues afin de
limiter l'effet d'aubaine et de ne pas
dégrader nos finances publiques le
présent amendement propose de recentrer
le dispositif contrat de génération sur
les entreprises qui en ont le plus
besoin aujourd'hui les entreprises où la
transmission des savoirs et les métiers
sont menacés du fait d'un manque
d'activité de d'attractivité pardon
métiers industriels notamment
ainsi l'amendement proposé permettent au
contrat de génération de réaliser sa
véritable vocation initiale
cette contrainte supplémentaire ne vise
que les entreprises de 50 à moins de 300
salariés sachant que les effets
d'aubaine risque - de s'appliquer aux
petites de 50 salariés je remercie
merci madame avis de la commission
madame demontès mais monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre
cher collègue madame la sénatrice debré
vous proposez donc de concentrer le
dispositif sur les entreprises employant
entre 50 et 300 salariés qui ont une
pyramide des âges inversée il me semble
que c'est un moment restera beaucoup
voire trop
le champ d'application du contrat de
génération
la gestion des âges des jeunes des
salariés âgés concerne toutes les
entreprises
c'est d'ailleurs le mérite du contrat de
génération que de proposer une approche
transversale et globale pour traiter ce
sujet la commission a émis un avis
défavorable sur cet amendement
merci madame à vis du gouvernement
monsieur le ministre oui monsieur le
président madame sénateurs on pourrait
comprendre la préoccupation y compris en
termes de diminution de la dépense
publique que de restreindre le champ
pourrait dire par exemple on le réserve
aux moins de 10 au moins de 50 au moins
de 306 ça y est c'est réservé au moins
de 300 pour ce qui est déjà de l'aide
elle même mais là vous faites un système
de sélection si je faisais des
entreprises qui d'avant me paraît assez
complexe je veux pas aller plus loin à
mettre en oeuvre
parce que qui va juger du fait que dans
cette entreprise là il y a absolument
besoin d'un transfert pour l'entreprise
d'à savoir faire alors que dans une
autre ce savoir-faire n'a pas besoin
d'être transmis je vous laisse imaginer
le travail de l'administration pour voir
les pour juger de quelle entreprise la
pyramide inversée est effectivement à
des effets négatifs pour l'entreprise et
ceux où elle en aurait pas vous voyez
bien que ce serait totalement impossible
à mettre en oeuvre mais je n'ai juste
attirer votre attention sur la logique
de votre amendement par rapport à la
logique du projet la logique de votre
amendement c'est de partir du besoin de
l'entreprise et vous dites puisque
l'entreprise a besoin de transférer à
savoir faire donc on le réserve à
l'entreprise qui a besoin de transférer
savoir faire c'est bien la logique de
votre abonnement je pense que c'est
dommage parce qu'il ya aussi des jeunes
qui ont besoin de travailler
il ya aussi des jeunes qui on veut
d'être embauchés et que ça peut être
aussi dans le tout à fait l'intérêt de
l'entreprise que d'embaucher un jeune et
donc il faut bien voir que la logique du
contrat de génération
c'est de réunir les trois préoccupations
l'embauchent de jeunes le maintien dans
l'emploi d'appui âgées et évidemment le
transfert de compétence qui est aussi
dans l'intérêt de l'entreprise
mais je dirais aussi ça ne peut pas être
le seul critère d'attribution de ce
contrat de génération merci monsieur le
ministre monsieur dsr vous savez madame
debré comment je salue votre travail et
votre perspicacité mais je suis quand
même surpris que je veux pas voter votre
amendement mais oui mais oui mais oui
monsieur le ministre mais souvent la
droite où la minorité sénatoriales où la
minorité va l'opposition présidentielle
nous diront enfin bon on peut tourner le
truc dans tous les sens bon et enfin le
côté droit de l'hémicycle à pâtir en
regardant de la présidence et vous nous
dites faut faut arrêter de contrôle et
il y en a marre combien de fois je vous
ai entendu le dire de ces dernières
années et là vous mettez assistait me
faudrait aller vérifier la pyramide des
âges vous rendez compte
alors que justement énorme mais on peut
pas à la fois dire des choses une
journée trois jours
et puis un an après dire le contraire
est renforcé quand même faut voir ce que
ça veut dire
vérifiez la pyramide des ha ces
entreprises ça veut dire que ce sont du
personnel en plus en plus vous opposez
je crois qu'on va voir
mais sur la transformation des statuts
des contrôleurs du travail en inspecteur
du travail alors faut savoir faut savoir
une certaine logique donc là c'est
vraiment un désaccord et si je suis
intervenu ce n'était pas simplement pour
vous mettre en difficulté madame la
sénatrice
mais c'est également parce que je pense
que vous ne comprenez pas la dynamique
qui est créée la sq et vous ne comprenez
pas parce que vous avez refusé
hier tout contrat 30 reprise j'étais
quand même très surpris de ce mot de
toutes contraintes aux entreprises
il est quand même important que les
entreprises jouent un rôle citoyen
qu'elle ne se contente pas d'exploiter
les gens mais qu'elle aime un rôle par
rapport à la collectivité et elles ont
un rôle par rapport à la pyramide des
âges à la fois pour l'entreprise mais
elles ont un rôle vis-à-vis de
l'embauché des seniors et des jeunes par
rapport à la société et c'est dans ce
sens que je combats vraiment votre
amendement merci mon cher collègue je
vais donc mettre aux voix madame de
bruit je vous en prie oui vous me dites
que c'est compliqué vous me dites mais
regardez le projet de loi vous parlez de
vérification partout vous parler de
sanctions deux pénalités pour avoir des
sanctions pour avoir des pénalités il
faut bien qu'il y ait des contrôles
donc c'est vous qui me reprocher de
mettre un contrôle en plus attendez là
c'est franchement l'hôpital qui se moque
de la charité
là franchement ce que je dis pourquoi
cet amendement effectivement nous sommes
soucieux des deniers de l'état
on dit que ça va coûter un milliard
d'euros monsieur le ministre vous avez
confirmé que ce que je disais c'est bien
par an en vitesse de croisière un
milliard d'euros ça ne se disperse pas
comme ça dans la nature sans rien c'est
pour ça qu'on a voulu effectivement
ciblées en fait c'est ces milliards
d'euros ce milliard d'euros et
d'ailleurs certains économistes disent
que ça irait peut-être presque jusqu'à 2
en tout cas avec les emplois d'avenir ça
fera au moins deux milliards par an et
c'est vrai que l'opposition actuelle
l'ex majorité est très soucieux des
deniers de l'état
merci madame je vais montreuillois donc
l'amendement 42 rectifié bis rectifié
pardon qui a reçu l'avis défavorable de
la commission et du gouvernement
quels sont ceux qui sont pour son
adoption
avis contraire il n'est pas adopté un
amendement 54 rectifié madame procas ya
six mois
cet amendement pour lequel je ne me fais
pas beaucoup d'illusions puisque il vise
à supprimer une disposition qui a été
introduite par madame le rapporteur nous
paraît met une procédure très lourde et
si l'on veut effectivement qu'il y ait
des contrats de génération dans les
entreprises en particulier pour tout ce
qui est tpe et pme
ça nous paraît être encore alourdir un
processus qui avait été mise en place et
qui est proposée par le sénat ce que je
regrette
merci madame avis de la commission
madame le rapporteur c'est le président
qui ce ministre mais quand chaque
collègue m'a impro cassia l'amendement
donc que vous proposez vise à supprimer
l'obligation de signer le procès verbal
de désaccord pour l'entrepreneur avec
les institutions représentatives du
personnel lorsqu'il n'y a pas
d'organisation syndicale
donc c'est où la houle autres donc on
alloue dit rien du tout dans la
procédure
d'autre part vous l'avez dit vous
revenez sur une disposition qui a été
introduite la semaine dernière en
commission sur le pv le procès verbal de
désaccord
donc je confirme l'avis défavorable de
la commission sur cet amendement
merci madame à vis du gouvernement
monsieur le ministre mais ma vie je vais
donc mettre aux voix l'amendement 54
rectifié qui a reçu l'avis défavorable
et du gouvernement et de la commission
quels sont ceux qui sont pour son
adoption
avis contraire il n'est pas adoptée nous
en arrivons à deux amendements faisant
l'objet d'une discussion commune le 40e
rectifié 41 rectifié madame de brèves ou
défendre les deux oui merci monsieur
président
mise sur collègues le projet doit doit
reposer sur une logique de dialogue
social et non de coercition de plus le
dispositif des contrats de génération
était censée inciter les entreprises à
embaucher des jeunes afin qu'ils soient
formés par un senior et non sanctionnée
celle qui ne prévoirait pas de le faire
sanctionner les entreprises qui ne
voudrait pas mais surtout ne pourrait
pas regard de la conjoncture actuelle
s'engager sur des objectifs d'embauché
semblent hors de propos et contribue à
entretenir un climat malsain de défiance
vis-à-vis des entreprises
le présent amendement a donc pour objet
de supprimer les pénalités prévues en
cas d'absence de signature d'un contrat
collectif de groupe ou d'un plan
d'actions par l'entreprise et
l'amendement 41 je le défends maintenant
mesures visant cet amendement de repli
vise à assouplir c'est un amendement de
repli par rapport à celui précédant
assouplir le dispositif de sanctions mis
en place par le projet de loi vis-à-vis
des entreprises de plus de 300 salariés
qui ne mettrait pas en place un accord
collectif de groupe ou d'un plan
d'action le projet de loi prévoyant une
date butoir au 30 septembre prochain il
s'agit également de faire en sorte que
le dispositif ne soit pas un carcan pour
les entreprises qui montreraient leur
bonne foi en s'engageant dans le
processus et qui aurait besoin de temps
pour conclure ces accords ainsi
l'amendement prévoit que la pénalité ne
sera pas encouru faute d'accord conclu
mais faute de négociations engagées
merci madame avis de la commission
madame le rapporteur même si le
président du ministre madame debré
madame la sénatrice sur l'article 40
rectifié jus pardon l'amendement 40
rectifié concernant la linea 20 excusez
moi
en fait votre amendement il constitue
une régression par rapport aux hackers
saignant de 2009 qui ont instauré une
pénalité de 1% de la masse salariale
dans les entreprises de plus de 50
salariés et qui ne respectent pas leurs
obligations en terme d'emploi des
seniors donc je ne vous rappelle pas qui
a permis les accords seniors de 2009
c'était à longages à l'occasion du
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale de 2009 donc adopté en
et adoptée par vous vous en madame la
sénatrice et les membres de votre groupe
concernant l'article l'abonnement 41
rectifié monsieur le président si vous
permettez vous l'avez dit madame debré
il s'agit d'un amendement de repli par
rapport à l'amendement 40
le texte de des contrats de génération
prévoit que les entreprises de tous les
établissements publics industriels et
commerciaux de plus 300 salariés
disposeront d'un peu plus de six mois
pour conclure un accord ou élaboré un
plan d'action ce délai franchement me
semble raisonnable
il me semble d'autant plus raisonnable
qu'une circulaire interministérielle du
mois d'octobre 2012 a demandé au service
des directs donc des services du
ministère des concentrés de sensibiliser
les entreprises sur la nécessité de
continuer les négociations sur l'emploi
des seniors dans la perspective des
prochaines négociations sur le contrat
de génération
donc je crois que tout le monde est bien
au courant dans les territoires par
ailleurs les services administratifs
tiendront compte de la situation de
l'entreprise au cas par cas pour le
calcul de la pénalité comme le prévoit
la linea 42 donc je confirme sur ces
deux amendements
l'avis défavorable de la commission
merci madame à vis du gouvernement
monsieur le ministre
même opinion donc c'est juste pour
confirmer que ce n'est pas les méchants
d'aujourd'hui qui aurait inventé une
épouvantable pénalité vis-à-vis des
entreprises
c'est en 2009 madame là je pense que
vous l'avez vous étiez présente dans cet
hémicycle
je pense que vous l'avez voter avec
enthousiasme vous avez donc créé une
obligation pour les entreprises de plus
de 300 et vous avez sanctionné ohlala si
le terme
quel terrible mot sanctionner les
entreprises qui ne respectait pas cette
obligation c'est exactement le même
dispositif que nous appliquons ni plus
ni moins j'irai même un tout petit peu
plus loin vous aviez prévu au même
moment que pour les entreprises de 50 à
c'était une obligation qui seraient
sanctionnés et nous avons voulu
simplifier et éviter de mettre des
obligations trop puissante sur des
coques des d'aider des entreprises de 50
à 300 et nous l'avons supprimés donc par
rapport à ce que vous avez voté avec
enthousiasme le texte est plus simple et
moins pénalisant pour les entreprises
merci monsieur mini je vais donc mettre
aux voix c'est à madame debré oui juste
une chose monsieur le ministre
effectivement il ya des choses qui ont
été voter comme je voulais dit le mot
sanctions revient systématiquement dans
ce projet de loi et je suis fâché sais
pas j'ai l'impression qu'on oublie
contre que nous traversons une crise
absolument sans précédent
alors avant la crise avaient démarré
aujourd'hui on est en plein dedans
donc je parlais surtout d'aider des
entreprises qui ne pourraient pas
embaucher donc franchement c'est pas
quelque chose c'est un amant de repli
par exemple par rapport au pardon par
rapport à ce que vous disiez c'est vrai
mais on sait très bien qu'aujourd'hui en
2012 2013
la crise est là nous sommes vraiment il
ya une conjoncture économique terrible
donc je trouve que remettre des
sanctions systématiquement voilà je ne
suis pas je n'ai pas là merci madame
monsieur cardo
le merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre j'ai dormi comme tout le
monde depuis hier soir
et quand vous aviez mis sur le sur le
fait que nous étions tard en soirée
quand je parlais d'une défiance à
l'égard des entreprises et bien après
réflexion en écoutant tous ces propos je
pense que je maintiens cette orientation
là alors bien évidemment vous faites
référence à des textes comme et
d'isabelle debré qui date de trois ans
dans un contexte économique et d'emplois
un peu différent mais néanmoins quand on
regarde l'ensemble de ce que vous
proposez est bien à chaque fois qu'on me
donne un avantage ou qu'on propose un
avantage on met tout de suite un
contrepoids qui va rendre la décision de
l'entreprise qui envisagerait de créer
un contrat de génération beaucoup plus
aléatoire parce que ils s'imaginent rond
à tout instant être remis en cause
et comme on le disait aussi précédemment
et bien avec les problèmes actuels
toute entreprise même importante n'a pas
une direction des ressources humaines
importantes n'a pas un service juridique
important et finalement je connais
beaucoup d'entrepreneurs que avec
lesquels je suis en contact
journellement dans mon département qui
disent à bois finalement oui c'est bien
mais on a tellement peur de se faire
aligner d'avoir des redressement
important si jamais pour la moindre
entorse à l'application de l'engagement
que nous avons pris et bien nous sommes
pénalisés
eh bien nous ne faisons pas donc je
crois qu'il faut trouver un équilibre
entre la juste utilisation des fonds
publics et la pression permanente mise
sur les entreprises pour les contrôler
et je répète que donc c'est vrai que si
vous pouvez dans la fonction publique
permettra d un des agents
d'administration d'avoir des promotions
c'est très bien chacun ne peut qu'y
souscrire
mais ce que vous nous avez annoncé de
transformer je ne sais pas combien de
contrôleurs du travail d'un inspecteur
du travail sachant comment certains de
ses agents pas tous évidemment
conçoivent leur rôle auprès des
entreprises je pense que il y a des
interrogations et des craintes qui
apparaîtront parmi les responsables
d'entreprises dans ce pays merci mon
cher collègue monsieur le ministre je
vous en prie on se présente ou pas du
tout allongé les débats mais simplement
donc vous vous une remarque
chacun voit bien qu'en 2009 surtout à la
fin de l'année 2009 puisque cette à
texte qui a été voté à la fin de l'année
2009 la situation économique était
extrêmement florissante
nous étions à moins combien en termes de
croissance du pib par rapport à
aujourd'hui donc vous avez voté ça en
pleine période de grandes difficultés et
vous avez eu raison de le faire
non pas parce que nous étions en grande
difficulté mais parce que ce plan senior
était une bonne chose était nécessaire
et que comme toujours
qu'est ce que c'est qu'une loi qui est
dit qu'une obligation sans sanction on
apprend ça dans le mon premier bouquin
de droit une obligation sans sanction ça
n'est pas une obligation
après il faut pas n'importe quelles
sanctions il faut pas des sanctions
appliquées n'importe comment
évidemment c'est comme ça que fonctionne
la société mais sinon s'il n'y a pas
d'obligation à une obligation sans
sanction et bâle obligations elle n'est
pas ou peu respectée
deuxième chose deuxième chose 16e je
dois y en a qui existe comme ça parce
que parfois on fait deuxième chose
vous nous dites il ya une préoccupation
de sécurité juridique il faut pas
sécuriser les entrées avait parfaitement
raison et c'est d'ailleurs parce que
vous avez parfaitement raison et que
nous avions déjà vu cette question là
auparavant avec les partenaires sociaux
il avait vu parce que c'est leur vie
dans l'entreprise que le texte lui-même
créé de la sécurité puisqu'il crée une
homologation auprès d'eux par la
direccte qui permet à l'entreprise
d'être ensuite tranquille l'homologation
ça veut dire vous avez rempli vos
obligations et personne derrière n'ira
en quelque sorte vous titiller pour
savoir si vous les avez rempli ou pas
non c'est vu c'est fait définitivement
clairement et c'est l'intérêt de tout le
monde
merci monsieur le ministre je vais donc
mettre voit les deux amendements
commençant par le 40 rectifié amendement
qui reçu l'avis défavorable du globe
man et de la commission quels sont ceux
qui sont pour l'adoption du 40è lee
contraire il n'est pas adoptée même vote
pour le 41 même vote
nous en arrivons à l'amendement 13 c'est
monsieur marseille qui le défend oui
monsieur le président c'est le ministre
chers collègues compte tenu de
l'importance des critères de contenu du
diagnostic économique et sociale de
l'entreprise
cet amendement pour objet d'inscrire
dans la loi plutôt que de le confier à
la au pouvoir réglementaire le soin de
les déterminer
en vertu de cet amendement ainsi il est
précisé que le diagnostic économique et
social de l'entreprise doit comprendre
un bilan de mesures de gestion du
personnel depuis un an la situation des
effectifs et leur répartition parole
cartographie des métiers et la pyramide
des âges les évolutions de compétences
nécessaires au regard de la stratégie de
l'entreprise pour tous les métiers les
prévisions de recrutement de jeunes on
s'est dit ainsi que les projections
d'effectifs pour l'année à venir
ce sont ainsi quelques statistiques qui
sont demandées parce que à nos yeux le
contrat de génération ne pourra produire
des effets vertueux que si sa mise en
oeuvre pourrait s'être d'une analyse
précise et fine du marché du travail
il s'agit autant que possible de coller
aux recommandations d'ailleurs de la
cour des comptes et du conseil
économique social et environnemental qui
insistent tous les deux sur la nécessité
de cibler les mesures territorialement
et par secteur d'activité je vous
remercie
merci mon cher collègue avis de la
commission madame le rapporteur si je me
casse la figure sur le président
monsieur le ministre
chaque collègue monsieur marseille
monsieur le sénateur vous à travers cet
amendement numéro 13 vous souhaitez
apporter des précisions sur le contenu
du diagnostic obligatoire qui je
rappelle est aussi une nouveauté par
rapport aux accords saignant en fait
votre votre amendement il renvoie à une
préoccupation constante que nous avons
eues à l'occasion de ce projet de loi
mais aussi que nous avons sur un grand
nombre de projets de loi que nous avons
à examiner qui est de pointer ce qui
relève de la loi et ce qui relève du
pouvoir réglementaire donc en
l'occurrence
je pense que les précisions que vous
apportez bien évidemment elles sont
importantes mais ne relève pas du
législateur et c'est d'ailleurs pour
cela qu à la commission des affaires
sociales de la semaine dernière nous
avions enlevé ces précisions
donc pour cette raison là je confirme
que la commission a émis un avis
défavorable à cet amendement
merci madame à vis du gouvernement
monsieur le ministre ce président g le
gêne même avis est il que les précisions
que vous apportez sont sont utiles sont
utiles dans l'absolu elles seront
d'ailleurs utile lorsque nous aurons à
mettre en place l'ensemble du dispositif
juridique qu'il s'agisse des décrets des
dispositions réglementaires ou toute
autre disposition permettant une bonne
application de la loi
donc vous dites là des choses qui
paraissent parfaitement légitime mais
ayant été très longtemps législateur
comme vous je suis aussi attaché à la
question de la qualité des lois n'ont
pas la qualité dans la rédaction la
rédaction est parfaite mais la qualité
dans le contenu juridique et on est
évidemment je dirais presque de manière
un peu caricaturale dans un domaine qui
n'est pas celui de la loi au sens de
l'article 34 de notre constitution
donc je me ferais défenseur de la
constitution de la vème république
en vous demandant de bien vouloir le
retirer mais je vous assure qu'il sera
pris en considération dans l'ensemble
des dispositions réglementaires
nécessaires pour l'application de cette
loi merci monsieur le ministre monsieur
marseille
nous retirerons monsieur le président
est retiré et nous en arrivons à
l'amendement de rectifier de monsieur
dés et soeurs
je président monsieur le ministre
monsieur reporter madame le rapporteur
chers collègues je vous ai déjà exprimé
en quoi ces contrats générations doivent
être porteurs d'un nouvel élan et en
particulier pour les entreprises
qu'elles deviennent plus citoyenne parce
que j'ai pas repris madame debré vos
arguments mais de dire je défends
l'entreprise comme cela comme si elles
étaient toutes les mêmes
il ya bien sûr des entreprises
socialement responsables
écologiquement responsable citoyenne
mais il ya des entreprises qui pensent
qu'au profit il ya des si le but de
l'entreprise c'est de créer de
l'activité pour produire un service ou
produire un bien les façons la façon
dont elle opère ne sont pas toutes
identiques
il ya quand même dans certaines
entreprises d exploitation des salariés
honteuse
donc il faut bien qu'il y ait quand même
un regard de la société sur l'activité
de certaines entreprises et cela m'amène
à mon amendement puisque on a beaucoup
parlé des stagiaires et de l'utilisation
abusive des stagiaires dans les
entreprises donc par cet amendement
j'amène l'idée qu'il faut un recensement
des stagiaires dans l'entreprise et de
voir s'il ya une utilisation abusive des
stagiaires d'entreprises donc le
diagnostic jolimont amendement présente
une répartition de l'ensemble des
employés de l'entreprise quel que soit
leur statut en s'appuyant sur les
données fournies par le registre unique
du personnel mentionnée à l'article l
1221 13 du code de travail et c'est la
spécificité de cet amendement par le
registre des conventions de stage
mentionnée à l'article l 612 13 du code
de l'éducation donc à la fois ça mène un
plus par rapport au projet de loi est à
la fois ça veut dire que ce projet de
loi s'inscrit dans une réforme de 2,2
société et qu'on considère que
l'entreprise doit avoir un rôle citoyen
la société merci monsieur dsr avis de la
commission madame le rapporteur oui
monsieur le sénateur la question de
l'intégration dans les contrats de
génération des stagiaires dans
l'entreprise je pense que sur tous les
bancs de cette assemblée nous y sommes
très favorables et nous y sommes
favorables parce que les entreprises ont
beaucoup joué et joue encore beaucoup
avec des stages qui remplace des cdi
voir qu'ils remplacent ceux des cdd donc
je pense que l'obligation que vous
demandez pour le diagnostic de s'appuyer
sur un registre unique du personnel elle
registre des conventions de stage me
paraît justifié
sauf qu apparemment le décret sur le
registre des conventions de stage n'a
pas été pris ensuite à la loi cherpion
de 2011 qui faisait suite à un accord
national interprofessionnel de juin 2011
donc hausse nous sommes effectivement
favorables à cette initiative mais je
pense qu'il nous faut demander l'avis du
gouvernement sur cette question là merci
quel est l'avis du gouvernement monsieur
le ministre
une double demande donc monsieur le
président d'abord je me permets de faire
une réponse qui se veut équilibré quand
je réponds à monsieur marseille en lui
disant dans ce domaine là je pense de
mon point de vue que nous sommes dans le
domaine réglementaire je ne peux pas
faire d'autre réponse à monsieur lessard
lorsqu'ils demandent des précisions
de même nature même si c'est pas les
mêmes que celles que demandait monsieur
marseille donc je ferai une première
réponse mais qui moi je n'ai pas de
conseil à donner aux législateurs averti
et est plein d'expérience que vous êtes
mais moi je j'attache de l'importance à
à la qualité de la loi et au respect de
ce qu'est l'ordre du législatif est de
l'ordre du réglementaire tout de ce
point de vue là nous sommes dans le
domaine réglementaire la preuve puisque
vous faites référence madame la
rapporteure un décret à certains décrets
n'ont paru mais un décret qui par
définition est du domaine réglementaire
donc vous faites en l'occurrence
allusion monsieur des essarts à des
dispositions manifestement d'ordre
réglementaire
je ne peux pas dire pour autant que
je ne partage pas votre préoccupation
sur les stagiaires gelé dit en réponse à
des questions qui m'étaient posées
depuis ce côté-ci de l'hémicycle je ne
peux donner que les mêmes réponses
de ce côté-là de l'hémicycle nous devons
nous prendrons nous prendrons des
mesures pour faire en sorte que dans les
entreprises il y à un accueil des
stagiaires qui ont besoin de stage mais
qu'il y ait une blague poursuite qu'on
poursuive les situations anormales comme
celle que vous voulez pouvoir détecter
par ce biais là où les entreprises ont
un abus dans l'utilisation des
stagiaires donc je vous avec mon
engagement je suis prêt d'ailleurs à ce
que moi même ou d'autres autour de moi
puisse en parler avec vous même vous
avez mon engagement sur la volonté qui
est la nôtre de lutter contre cet abus
de le faire par d'autres voies et compte
tenu de ses réponses aussi bien de forme
nous sommes dans le domaine
réglementaire que de fond la volonté
politique commune qui est la nôtre
peut-être pourriez-vous avoir la
possibilité de retirer votre amendement
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur
désessard lendemain retirait il est
maintenu il est maintenu alors je vais
donc le mettre aux voix
quels sont ceux qui sont pour l'adoption
de l'amendement de monsieur dsr avis
contraire
alors on va faire un assis debout pourra
s'assurer qu'elles sont ceux qui sont
pour l'adoption de l'amendement de
monsieur désessard combien alors avis
contraire combien il n'est pas adopté
elle nous en arrivons à l'amendement 14
rectifier c'est monsieur marseille qu'il
défend je président monsieur le ministre
l'objet de cet amant jeu cet amendement
est d'intégrer une obligation de
formation qualifiante dans tout accord
collectif d'entreprise sur des postes
permettant le recrutement de jeunes non
diplômés
je crois que c'est un souci partagé
comme l'a rapporté que l'a rappelé
madame le rapporteur tout à l'heure il
s'agit de satisfaire à notre
préoccupation constante que les contrats
de génération bénéficient en priorité à
des jeunes peu qualifiés et offre une
formation qualifiante sont les jeunes
les moins qualifiés en effet qui sont le
plus durement touchés par le chômage
la formation aux grandes absentes selon
nous du dispositif des contrats de
génération et donc pour ces jeunes un
enjeu clé si les jeunes peu qualifiés ne
sont pas les bénéficiaires prioritaires
des contrats de génération associée à
une formation nous craignons que le
dispositif ne fasse que déplacé de
l'emploi sans en créer
autrement dit nous voyons mal comment
dans ces conditions l'effet d'aubaine ne
jouerait pas à plein je vous remercie
merci monsieur marseille avait de la
commission madame demontès monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre chaque
collègue monsieur marseille en fait cet
amendement rectifié 14 rectifié nous ne
l'avons pas examiné en commission
puisqu'en la commission avait donné un
avis sur l'accès aux formations
qualifiantes
donc je vais m'exprimer en tant qu
rapportant mais pas en tant que quelques
commissions
moi je suis à titre personnel favorable
à cet amendement 14 rectifié parce qu il
insiste sur la nécessité de la formation
en particulier pour les jeunes les moins
qualifiés mais il n'a pas les
inconvénients que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure à l'occasion d'un l'amendement
numéro 11
donc monsieur le président j'ai mais un
avis favorable à cet amendement
merci madame rapporteur avait du
gouvernement monsieur le ministre si
monsieur le président messieurs
sénateurs vous avez eu la délicatesse de
retirer un amendement précédent en nous
renvoyant rendez vous sur cet amendement
numéro 14 donc nous allons vous donner
une réponse bien sûr sûr sûr son contenu
il est important
cet amendement je ne pense important par
l'esprit qu'est le sien et que le
gouvernement partage mais que nous ayons
bien en tête les choses il ne s'agit pas
d'un contrat aidé on a beaucoup parlé
hier c'est pas un contrat d c'est un
contrat de droit commun contrats droit
commun qui est le contrat à durée
indéterminée dont le jeune va pouvoir
bénéficier mais il est important de
souligner que s'agissant de contrats de
droit commun l'entreprise à des
obligations de formation ça s'appelle le
plan de formation et il est aussi
important de souligner ça n'est pas
toujours le cas dans les entreprises
qu'il serait bon que les plans de
formation soit plutôt tournées vers ceux
qui ont peu de qualifications et en
particulier ceux qui rentrent dans
l'entreprise que vis-à-vis de ceux qui
ont beaucoup d'expérience parfois
beaucoup de qualification mais qui
peuvent aussi avoir besoin d'une
formation complémentaire vous le savez
bien une des critiques que l'on fait
souvent au système de formation
professionnelle en france c'est
premièrement que les chômeurs ont très
peu de formation alors que ceux qui ont
un emploi ont plus de formation mais
dans ce qu'ils ont de la fin d'un emploi
c'est plutôt ceux qui ont déjà beaucoup
de formation qui bénéficie de la
formation donc vous soulignez à juste
titre la nécessité de prioriser sur les
jeunes qui ont le moins de formation au
sein d'entreprises les moyens de
l'entreprise bénéficient au titre du
plan de formation
donc nous ne quittons pas le cadre du
contrat de droit commun mais nous aide
conte à l'entreprise la nécessité de
faire des efforts particuliers pour ceux
qui ont besoin de cette qualification et
de cette formation
c'est la raison pour laquelle monsieur
le sénateur le gouvernement donne un
avis favorable à cet amendement
merci monsieur mini je vais donc mettre
aux voix l'amendement 14 rectifié qui a
reçu l'avis favorable de la commission
et du gouvernement quels sont ceux qui
sont pour son adoption
avis contraire je n'en vois pas il est
donc adopté un amendement 59 de la
commission madame demontès une seule
président mes chers collègues il s'agit
là aussi de corriger une faute
d'expression donc il faut remplacer les
mots à contrat à durée indéterminée en
contrat à durée indéterminée je vous
prie de bien vouloir m'excuser merci à
vis du gouvernement monsieur le ministre
favorable je mets donc aux voix
l'amendement 59 de la commission quels
sont ceux qui sont pour son adoption
avis contraire je n'en vois pas il est
adopté un amendement numéro 9 c'est
monsieur marseille qui le défend
le 9 monsieur marseille il a défendu à
vide
la commission madame rapporteur il me
semblait qu'il avait été retiré mais ça
fait rien il est il s'agit pour les
auteurs de l'amendement d'introduire le
terme par an pour désigner le référent
et l'obligation imposée à ce dernier de
viser le contrat de travail du jeune il
me semble on en a déjà débattu
longuement à la commission que le terme
de référence qui a été retenu dans la
nuit du 19 octobre 2012
évite les confusions avec les mots aux
maîtres d'apprentissage tuteur donc je
ne pense pas souhaitable d'introduire
encore un autre terme
en plus je pense que le terme de visakh
du référent lors de la conclusion du
contrat de travail du jeune on ne doit
pas avoir une portée juridique
exemplaires pour ces deux raisons la
commission a émis un avis défavorable à
cet amendement
merci ma le rapporteur avait du
gouvernement même avis monsieur le
ministre
avis défavorable il est maintenu non il
est retiré suite aux explications de
madame le rapporteur effectivement ils
n'ont pas les affublé d'un nom
supplémentaire qui risquerait de
pénaliser donc retiré amendement numéro
10 vous avez la parole monsieur
marseille pour le dise monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues exactement dans le même esprit
que les événements précédents celui ci
prévoit que l'accord collectif distingue
les référents directement chargé des
jeunes des seniors qui n'assure pas
concrètement le transfert des
connaissances et des compétences
en vertu de cet amendement l'accord
devra également préciser le rôle
spécifique et les missions du référent
distinguent de ceux de l'accompagnement
chargée de l'accueil du jeune et de la
découverte de l'entreprise il s'agit une
fois ti c'est véritablement un lien
intergénérationnel entre les deux
membres du binôme placé au centre du
dispositif de ce contrat de génération
merci mon cher collègue avis de la
commission madame demontès monsieur le
président chaque collègue
je vais faire deux de remarques et deux
types de réponses sur cet amendement
le premier sur le fond qui est de même
nature que mon propos a à l'occasion de
l'amendement numéro 9
rajouter encore des termes je pense que
ça ne simplifie pas la lisibilité et en
plus il s'agit de dispositions de nature
réglementaire
donc la commission a émis un avis
défavorable sur cet amendement
merci à vis du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre
même à votre jeu mais donc on voit cet
amendement quels sont ceux qui sont pour
son adoption
l'amendement 10 de monsieur marseille
qui sont ceux qui sont pour son adoption
avis contraire il n'est pas adopté avant
devant 52 rectifié qui le présente
monsieur réquier vous avez la parole
ida monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues il s'agit d'un amendement de
précision à l'effet lors des débats à
l'assemblée nationale les députés ont
adopté un amendement qui me posait aux
accords collectifs d'entreprise ou de
groupe de préciser les mesures destinées
à favoriser l'amélioration et adaptation
des conditions d'emploi des salariés
âgés de 10 à g la commission des
affaires sociales du sénat
ces propositions ne le rapporteur à la
modifier rédaction pour que l'accord
collectif d'entreprise de groupe ou de
branches comporte des mesures destinées
à favoriser l'amélioration des
conditions de travail et de la
prévention de la pénibilité
elle a ainsi choisi de reprendre l'un
des sept thèmes retenus à l'article 6 de
l'accord national interprofessionnel du
19 octobre 2012 est antique 6 est
intitulé emploi des seniors
nous proposons donc d'ajouter à cette
rédaction issue des travaux d'autres
commissions les mots salariés âgés terme
aucun le projet de loi faisait référence
à six reprises je sais bien que ce terme
âgées ne plaît pas beaucoup mais là je
laisse couler est une réalité et en plus
c'est y est tout à fait en cohérence
avec le projet de loi merci monsieur
recchi avait de la commission madame
demontès oui monsieur le président chers
collègues
monsieur le sénateur krecké vous
ou cet amendement 50 de rectifier
précise un certain nombre de choses je
rappelle d'ailleurs que la commission
des affaires sociales avait déjà
introduit sur les salariés concernés par
l'amélioration des conditions de travail
on avait insisté aussi sur la prévention
de la pénibilité
donc je voulais en profiter pour pour le
rappeler pour ce qui concerne
précisément cet amendement
l'alinéa 28 reprend les termes de
l'article 6 de l'ani de l'accord
national interprofessionnel d'octobre
aussi cet amendement ajoute la mention
de salariés âgés tels que cela figure
dans l'accord national
interprofessionnel ça me semble une
bonne chose
suite au débat qu'on a eu ce matin en
commission des affaires sociales parce
qu'il ya eu un vrai débat
ce non pas sur le thème sur le terme des
salariés âgés mais pourquoi réduire la
question des conditions de
l'amélioration des conditions de travail
et de la prévention de la pénibilité
seulement salariés âgés moi je fais
l'hypothèse que en travaillant sur les
conditions de travail et la prévention
de la pénibilité pour les salariés âgés
l'entreprise travaille pour l'ensemble
des salariés les jeunes les plus de 45
ans un qui sont juste en face de devenir
âgées d'ailleurs dans les maintenant
dans les termes
donc je pense que c'est cette précision
et cet amendement est tout à fait
intéressant et donc la commission a émis
un avis favorable à cet amendement
merci madame rapporteur monsieur le
ministre
merci monsieur le ministre je mets donc
aux voix l'amendement 50 de rectifier de
monsieur réquier quels sont ceux qui
sont pour son amendement
son adoption pardon avis contraire il
est adopté
nous en arrivons à trois amendements en
discussion commune dont le
numéro 62 la commission madame demontès
oui il s'agit monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs se
munissent d'un amendement de cohérence
en effet il y avait un alinéa 29 que je
vous propose de supprimer parce qu'il
renvoie au décret visant à préciser les
domaines d'action et donc il me semble
que cet alinéa 29 n'est pas sa bonne
place donc je vous propose de le
supprimer et de créer un autre alinéa
qui se situe après la linea 33 puisque
son nez à la fin des modalités et donc
il me semble que le renvoi au décret
plus logique à la fin des modalités
merci amendement 16 monsieur marseille
le président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues l'accord collectif ou le
plan d'action peuvent comporter des
mesures destinées à favoriser
l'amélioration des conditions de travail
et la prévention de la pénibilité
il est également prévu qu'il pourra
comporter aussi des engagements dans
d'autres domaines d'action la définition
de ces engagements et renvoyées à un
décret en conseil d'état
l'objet du présent amendement est de
prévoir que ses autres domaines d'action
le soit dans le cadre d'une démarche
territoriale de gestion prévisionnelle
des emplois et des compétences s'agit là
de satisfaire à une préoccupation
constante que le dispositif de contrat
de génération soit mis en oeuvre au plus
près possible du terrain de manière à
satisfaire les besoins réels des bassins
d'emploi présents et prospectif et de
s'articuler avec les programmes des
missions locales maison de l'emploi et
plans locaux pour l'insertion et
l'emploi
la territorialisation des contrats de
génération est selon nous un enjeu
majeur comme il était d'ailleurs pour
les contrats d'avenir
mais alors que le gouvernement l'avait
placé au fondement de ce dernier
dispositif il est curieusement avec la
formation grand oublié de cette réforme
comme on a pu le déjà le souligner dans
les interventions pourquoi adopter une
démarche territoriale pour les emplois
d'avenir et non pour les contrats de
génération
l'omission et d'auto moins intelligible
que la territorialisation du dispositif
est imposé par la nécessité rappelée
temps là encore par la cour des comptes
que le conseil économique social et
environ
mental qui demande de cibler ce type de
dispositif sur les secteurs d'activité
qui en ont le plus besoin
je vous remercie merci amendement numéro
30 rectifié madame debré président et
ses ministres chers collègues le texte
de l'accord national interprofessionnel
du 19 octobre 2012
le projet de loi déposé par le
gouvernement prévoyait que l'accord
collectif devrait prendre en compte
l'égalité professionnelle entre les
femmes et les hommes
l'assemblée nationale a remplacé cette
obligation de moyens par l'introduction
d'une double obligation de résultat
assurer la réalisation d'objectifs
d'égalité professionnelle d'une part
entre les hommes et les femmes
d'autre part dans le cadre de la lutte
contre les discriminations à l'embauché
une telle obligation exposerait
l'entreprise à une éventuelle sanction
lorsqu elle n'atteindrait pas les
objectifs imposés
cela risque d'avoir un effet doublement
contre-productif
les employeurs fixeront des objectifs a
minima dans leurs accords collectifs en
matière d'égalité professionnelle et de
lutte contre les discriminations dans
les négociations des accords les
délégués syndicaux pourraient avoir des
exigences très contraignante pour les
entreprises
tout cela compromettrait les chances de
conclure un accord en remplaçant le mot
assure par le mot contribuer à le
législateur sera plus conforme à
l'esprit de l'accord qui consiste à
accorder une grande confiance au
dialogue social à tous les nouveaux tous
les niveaux merci madame avis de la
commission madame le rapporteur sur
l'amendement 16 et 30 rectifier alors
monsieur le président mes chers
collègues sur l'amendement 16 qui fait
référence aux accords de partenariat gps
et territoriales alors je voudrais vous
vous rappelez chers collègues que ces
accords de partenariat de gestion
prévisionnelle des emplois et des
compétences territoriales sont issus
d'un autre accord national
interprofessionnel celui du mois de
novembre 2008
ces accords d'ailleurs peuvent être
conclus entre de nombreux acteurs des
organisations interprofessionnelles des
regroupements d'entreprises des
collectivités territoriales
des acteurs du secteur associatif des
chambres consulaires pour l'emploi et
j'en passe le territoire concerné est
aussi de taille très variable
ça peut être la région ça peut être le
niveau inter régional le but de la gto
ses eaux territoriales et d'encourager
et soutenir dans les bassins d'emploi
confronté à des mutations économiques
des démarches globales ou thématiques
pour sécuriser les parcours
professionnels d'actifs employés ou non
occupés ou non
le ton général moyens d'intervention de
l'état et de 33%
l'amendement 16 numéros 16 vise à
inscrire tous les domaines d'action
prévue par le décret en conseil d'état
dans des geôles gp oc territorialisées
ce qui me semble extrêmement rectrice
restrictif et deux majeurs pour le
projet de loi qui nous occupe
aujourd'hui donc il me semble qu'il ne
faut pas bloquer le contrat de
génération avec des objectifs trop
ambitieux de rajouter des obligations en
supplémentaire c'est pour cette raison
que la commission a émis un avis
défavorable pour ce qui concerne
monsieur le président l'avis de la
commission sur le 30
l'amendement 30 rectifié de madame debré
et de ses collègues
madame debré vous l'avais dit à travers
votre amendement vous fixer une
obligation de moyens et non de résultat
pour les objectifs d'égalité
professionnelle et de lutte contre les
discriminations serait que sur lesquels
d'ailleurs la commission des affaires
sociales du sénat a apporté des
compléments
puisque nous parlons de la lutte contre
les discriminations à l'embauché mais
que nous avons également rajouté et
durant le déroulement de la carrière
parce que c'est aussi une réalité et en
rajoutant cela nous pensons
principalement aux femmes qui n'ont pas
forcément les mêmes déroulements de
carrière que les hommes pour des raisons
qui leur sont spécifiques
donc notre compte notre en commission a
précisé que la réalisation de ces
objectifs se fait dans le strict cadre
des accords contre
à deux générations c'est pour cette
raison que l'amendement 30 nous
paraissant comme en retrait par rapport
à la position de notre commission nous
avons émis un avis défavorable
merci madame à vis du gouvernement sur
les trois amendements monsieur le
ministre
oui merci monsieur le président madame
reporter vient d'être extrêmement
précises s'agissant de l'abonnement
numéro 30 et de l'événement numéro 16
donc je partage le même avis pour les
mêmes raisons et je veux donner un avis
favorable à l'amendement numéro 60 me
semble-t-il de la commission merci
monsieur le mini je vais donc mettre aux
voix l'amendement 60 et je suis saisi
d'une demande de scrutin public par le
groupe socialiste et nous allons donc
procéder aux opérations de vote
je demande donc à madame et messieurs
les secrétaires de bien vouloir procéder
au vote
voilà
vous aimez
c
le scrutin est ouvert
plus personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin est clos et j'invite mesdames et
messieurs les secrétaires a procédé au
dépouillement du scrutin
je
résultat donc du scrutin 96 sur
l'amendement 60 équipes aux 60 de
l'article 1 du projet de loi de
mondement de la commission nombre de
votants 178 nombre de suffrages exprimés
178 majorité absolue des suffrages
exprimés 90 pour l'adoption 177 contre 1
l'amendement 60 est adopté et en
conséquence les amendements 16 et 30
rectifié tombe
nous quittons l'hémicycle du sénat merci
à vous d'avoir suivi cette séance nous
reviendrons le plus largement dans notre
édition de 19h sur les contrats de
génération alors restez avec nous bonne
soirée à tous